Taylor Matt wall show we are still
playing offense here in Tennessee not
only are we Banning child mutilation but
we're also going to criminalize child
drag shows also a d-transition or sues
the medical professionals quote unquote
who butchered her an obese man wins a
Miss America Pageant the rather
one-sided Trump versus DeSantis War
heats up and somebody allegedly finds a
noose at the construction site for
Obama's presidential Center these
stories are literally always hoaxes is
this one any different almost certainly
not but we'll talk about it all that and
more today on the Matt Walsh show
[Applause]
[Music]
the Supreme Court decision to overturn
Roe is a huge albeit long overdue step
in the right direction but there's still
a long way to go to rid our country of
abortion many companies are bowing to
the woke mob by donating to pro-choice
causes of candidates or reimbursing
their employees travel expenses so that
if they live and work in a pro-life
State they can travel to a pro-abortion
state get an abortion to be back at work
on Monday but what if I told you that if
you're currently on a phone plan with
one of the major carriers you might be
supporting these companies and their Pro
abortion agendas with your monthly phone
bill whether you want to or not don't
let abortionists use your money to fund
policies you don't believe in switch to
Charity mobile instead Charity mobile is
a pro-life Pro family cell phone company
that sends five percent of your monthly
plan price to the pro-life charity of
your choice you don't have to compromise
on values or good phone service Charity
mobile offers the latest 5G phones no
device or service contracts great
Nationwide coverage a live customer
service also based right here in the U.S
the fight for the right to life
continues and pro-life causes needs your
support you can help us simply switching
to Charity mobile call
1-877-474-3662 or chat with them on line
at charitymobile.com mentioned offer
code walls to redeem a free cell phone
that's charitymobile.com mention offer
code Walsh
well this is a time when many
conservatives are licking their wounds
sulking whining even worse they're
sniping at each other and this is all of
course a massive mistake now you know I
may not be the greatest Bastion of
optimism and positivity in the world I
realize that I'm not the guy you turn to
for pep talk usually but
I also am not one for pouting and it's
Unbecoming of a grown man to pout or
sulk and besides I prefer to stay on
offense even after a loss in fact
especially after a loss and that's why
we're still playing offense here in
Tennessee I've already told you about
the bill file this week the very first
piece of legislation in the session Bill
one which will um ban so-called gender
affirmation quote unquote procedures on
minors
and the media has lamented that our bill
is among the strictest in the nation and
I will uh proudly admit that we are
guilty as charged as far as that goes
our legislation not only bans the
medical abuse of gender confused minors
but it also empowers the victims to sue
those who are responsible for it and and
what I believe I believe this is an
unprecedented step the victims of this
Butchery will even be given the right to
sue their parents after all parents who
bring their children to doctors to be
sterilized and castrated and butchered
are the primary villains here even more
than the doctors I would say
I mean the doctor is a mercenary fraud
hurting children for profit betraying
his oath to do no harm it's hard to get
lower than that but the parents somehow
succeed as they have are they are bound
by an oath before God to love and
protect their children whether they have
said such an oath out loud or not they
are bound by it from the moment that
their children are conceived
and those parents who fail to live up to
it
will pay the price as as well they
should
but child abuse comes in many and
diverse and deranged forms uh these days
and our goal must be to root it out
expose it punish it in every form that
brings us to Bill three of the
legislative session just filed by
Tennessee Senate Majority Leader Jack
Johnson also one of the principal
architects of uh our anti-mutilation
bill
Bill 3 will ban and criminalize any drag
performance involving children the hill
reports quote Tennessee Senate Majority
Leader Jack Johnson Republican has
introduced legislation to prohibit drag
entertainers from performing on public
property or at private functions where
their performance may be viewed by a
minor Johnson's bill would amend a state
law preventing adult-oriented businesses
like strip clubs from operating within a
thousand feet of schools public public
parks or places of worship to include
adult Cabaret performances including
those of exotic dancers and male or
female impersonators Johnson told WKRN
TV in Nashville this week that the bill
is designed to prevent drag shows that
are sexual in nature from being
performed in places where children may
be present should the bill Advance
through Tennessee's
republican-controlled legislature and
receive the approval of Governor Bill
Lee boasted with both of which things I
think certainly will happen first time
offenders would be guilty of a Class A
misdemeanor punishable by jail time of
up to a year and a fine of 2500 repeat
offenders would be charged with a Class
E felony which carries a prison sentence
of up to six years and fines totaling up
to three thousand dollars
so we have the anti-mutilation built
this now is the anti-groomer bill
and predictably the groomers are not
happy about it our local news channel 5
interviewed uh some some in the latter
group the groomers who are upset to get
their reaction and uh let's see some of
that
this bill would also ban drag shows
where children may be present it's
extremely uh hurtful Mac puts on
pageants for male impersonators and
Divas
and she's the Nashville Pride president
it would devastate our pride parade our
pride festivals according to state
senator Jack Johnson they were
inappropriate performances in public
which sparked the bill it is illegal to
take your child to a strip club and yet
we're going to allow a drag show that
has blatantly explicit sexual activity
taking place in a public park where kids
are present no we're going to stop that
we also talked to Chris Sanders at the
Tennessee equality project he says it's
frustrating that the first two bills
introduced for this legislative season
Target them merely dressing in the
clothing of a different gender is not
something that should be regulated ever
not in our American tradition not
according to our constitution in the
Bill of Rights and not according to
common sense if dry kings and queens
perform in public they could be charged
with a misdemeanor and the second
offense is a felony it's just not right
it's not our American tradition the
stifle expression Rebecca Phil's freedom
of speech and expression should be
protected the wording is very violent to
trans people and it's dangerous and it's
homophobic and I think that there's a
very slippery slope
a slippery slope yes watch out for that
slippery slope folks first you tell
adults they can't perform in Burlesque
for children and the next thing you know
uh
chaos has ensued and by chaos we mean
that children are given the basic
protections they need and deserve this
is what counts as chaos in the minds of
the groomers
indeed it is homophobic she says because
apparently in her mind sexual
performances for children are a
fundamental and inextricable part of Gay
Culture that is her claim evidently
that's what she is saying
there's a reason why these people panic
over the possibility that they may not
be able to sexualize Children anymore
for one thing they get a thrill out of
doing so they derive sick satisfaction
from it and they're upset that they're
uh that this favorite pastime of theirs
will now be taken away but they also
realize that their ideological project
their cultural agenda depends on
destroying childhood innocence as
quickly and efficiently as possible
and they're going to find it more
difficult to recruit children into their
cult if they can't first corrupt them
and that's why they're upset
so I make that's why this law is
necessary and similar laws should be
adopted in every red state in the
country if you live in Red State doesn't
have a law like this uh you need to be
reaching out to your local legislators
and asking them why you don't
but there are you know other other you
know basically this all boils down to
the benefits of a law like this first
the most obvious benefit is again it
protects kids you know in this country
there are special laws and policies put
in place to protect all kinds of
different special groups and victim
classes and usually the laws are
unnecessary and the special group
neither needs nor deserves nor has any
legal right to the extra protections
that they're being given
but children are in fact a special group
and they are in fact morally and legally
entitled to extra protections
the law is meant to treat them
differently
with special care and concern for their
well-being
but largely because we recognize that
they can't fully watch out for and care
for themselves
and so and so then they functional and
decent Society recognizes that
and offers them extra protections
you could tell everything you need to
know about a society based on how it
treats its children and based on what it
law what its laws say about children
and that's how you know that we are a
depraved and dying Society because
children are not only deprived of
special protections even as special
protections are awarded to groups of
infantilized adults but worse the law
often specifically denies children even
the most basic and fundamental rights of
protections that everybody else has such
as the right to life
this is all backwards
and we're going to set it right
second politically this is a winner
because not only do decent Americans
want kids to be protected but also it
puts the other side in the position uh
that you you heard in that news clip of
having to explicitly defend and
affirmatively argue for the sexual
exploitation of children
we already know that they're in favor of
such things but if you don't wage a
legal assault on it they'll never have
to openly own this horrific position
it's good for the public to hear
when they they make the case it's good
for the public to hear them make the
case
so the public can see
who they are
third finally
you know politics may be Downstream from
culture
but also sometimes culture is Downstream
from politics it's not quite as simple
as we sometimes make it out to be and
what I mean is that when the law is
permissive of something
the public is more likely to see that
thing as morally acceptable
when the law forbids something
the public is more likely to see it as
morally unacceptable
this is just a fact
um the the the law is not simply a
reflection of public opinion
sometimes it doesn't reflect public
opinion at all
but at other times it also shapes public
opinion
this is why the left fight so hard to
change the law to accommodate and affirm
their wickedness and their various
perversions
they do it not just so that they have
permission to act as they want
but also so that the public will see
their actions as acceptable even
admirable
this is why we have to fight
in the culture
but also in the State House
and that's what we're trying to do here
we aren't dissuaded I'm certainly not
in fact I never felt more motivated
now let's get to our five headlines
well if you're listening to this show
odds are that you put a lot of stock and
how you raise your kids you understand
that your children look to you to Define
your values and their perspectives of
the world that's why it's extremely
important that you have a will in place
a will also determines how your
financial assets are dispersed as well
as your personal property it lays out
your health care power of attorney to
ensure that your end of life decisions
are carried out if you're just starting
out and you don't have thousands of
dollars to spend on an attorney but you
want to make sure your savings your
belongings and your family are all
protected you have to create your will
at epicwill.com today epic Wells early
estate plans started just 119 and you
can save 10 when you use uh promo code
Walsh go to epicwill.com use code Walsh
to save 10 on Epic Will's complete will
package that's epicwill.com promo code
Welsh
Okay so
speaking of pouting and sniping that
brings us unfortunately
to uh
president Trump this is from the daily
wire
I don't even want to talk about this
stuff like like as I said at the top
uh
I I although and as I've been saying
since Tuesday although the Red Wave
didn't come to pass and all that kind of
stuff then it was a disappointment
I don't see it as the unmitigated
catastrophe the disaster lots of other
people see it as I see opportunities
here and so I'd rather focus on that
but we talk about the news on this show
as well especially in the five headlines
and uh well this unfortunately is the
biggest headline in politics right now
so this is from the daily wire it says
former president uh Trump followed up an
unprovoked attack on Florida's Ron
DeSantis with a strange swipe Friday
morning at another popular Republican
Governor Glenn youngkin of Virginia in
both cases the former president who's
expected again to seek the White House
in 2024. uh claimed credit for the
success of his targets while the attack
on DeSantis was withering the comments
about youngkin included a bizarre
observation about his name and a
backhanded vote of confidence
so he wrote on Truth social young kin
now that's an interesting take sounds
Chinese doesn't it
what
in Virginia couldn't have won without me
I endorsed him did a very big pro-trump
a trump rally for him telephonically got
magga to vote for him or he couldn't
have come close to winning but he knows
that and admits it besides having a hard
time with the Dems in Virginia but he'll
get it done
okay first of all it's just I'm sorry
that's just not true at all
um the uh the Red Wave in Virginia
DeSantis uh rather youngin winning in
Virginia
it I mean Trump might have attached
himself to that late in the game but
that was like work on the ground that
was work that we were doing okay that's
that's where that came from those were
people mobilized for issues like on the
issues it was it wasn't people mobilized
because they loved Trump although many
of the young kids voters might like
Trump
but I think it's like insulting to them
to say that's what it was all about oh
they just came out to vote because they
like Trump that was a lot more
substantive than that
it wasn't even just that they came out
because they personally love Junkin
what made Virginia so significant is
that they were they were really and I
was there I know they were I lived there
as you know that was my I that's my home
state
and uh they were motivated by the issues
and they were especially motivated to
protect their kids that's why they they
they showed up and that's why they voted
young kid in is because these were
parents protecting their children
um that was it
as far as his his uh attack on DeSantis
and by the way with the Chinese name
thing like I don't even know what that
is
um except more evidence that Trump
unfortunately is losing his touch when
it comes to to nicknames and I know for
that you know you're going to hear some
people say well that's not an attack
that's not an insult that was a it's
just funny it's so funny first of all
it's not funny like come on this is not
that's not clever uh but this is also
what they said about when when he said
the sanctimonious and apologists last
week we're saying well I'm just a clever
little funny dig at him you know it's
just just as friends do
and then what do you know a day later he
launches into this full-on attack so
yeah he he starts with the nickname and
then he goes into the the to the full
attack and so we can expect that's going
to happen with Junkin as well
um but here's what he said but he put
out a statement yesterday about DeSantis
and here's what it says News Corp which
is Fox The Wall Street Journal and the
no longer great New York Post uh is all
in for governor Ron de sanctimonious an
average Republican governor with great
public relations who didn't have to
close up his state but did unlike other
Republican Governors whose overall
numbers for Republican were just average
middle of the pack including covid and
who has the advantage of sunshine where
people from badly run States up north
would go no matter who the governor was
just like I did that's all one sentence
by the way
Ron came to me in Desperate shape in
2017 he was politically dead losing in a
landslide to a very good agricultural
Commissioner Adam Putnam who was loaded
up with cash and great poll numbers Ron
had low approval bad polls and no money
but he said that if I would endorse him
he could win I didn't know Adam so I
said let's give it a shot Ron when I
endorsed him it was as though to use a
bad term a nuclear weapon went off years
later there were the exact words that
Adam Putnam used in describing Ron's
endorsement he said I went from having
it made with no competition to
immediately getting absolutely clobbered
after your endorsement I then got run by
the star of the Democrat Party uh Andrew
Gillum by having two massive rallies
with tens of thousands of people at each
one I also fixed his campaign which had
completely Fallen apart I was all in for
Ron and he beat Gillum but after the
race when votes were being stolen by the
corrupt election process in Broward
County and Ron was going down 10 000
votes a day along with now Senator Rick
Scott I sent in the FBI and the U.S
attorneys in the ballot theft
immediately ended just prior to them
running out of the votes necessary to
win I I stopped his election from being
stolen and now Rhonda sanctimonas is
playing games the fake news asks if he's
going to run if president Trump runs and
he says I'm only focused on the
governor's race well in terms of loyalty
in class that's really not the right
answer this is just 2015 and 2016 and
media assault when Fox News fought me to
the end until I won and I couldn't have
been nicer and more supportive The Wall
Street Journal loved low energy Jeb Bush
in a secession of other people as they
rapidly disappeared from sight finally
falling in line with me after I easily
knocked them out one by one we're in
exactly the same position now they will
keep coming after us Maga But ultimately
we will put America first and make
America great again me me me me okay
um
I don't even know where to begin I mean
first of all going after DeSantis on
covid is just suicidal are you kidding
me I mean rot now it's true that that uh
I don't think that any
public official in the United States is
entirely 100 innocent when it comes to
the lockdowns I as far as I know and
Craig on that but I think every state in
the country for at least a period of
time locked down to some brief extent
uh so that's true you know and and and
so we could just like throw everybody
out and just dismiss everybody based on
that
or we can allow for the fact that uh in
the very very very early going uh it was
just people didn't know exactly what was
going on and some decisions were made
and not all that were good
in the very very very very beginning
okay
but then quickly the dust started to
settle or it should have and people
started to see very clearly or at least
some people did and that's when uh you
know uh very quickly Ron DeSantis became
an anti-lockdown governor and that's why
they the media labeled him remember
death santis
and once he settled on that he stuck to
it you know there were different waves
and different this and that and they you
know they had the omnicron variant came
along and all the different variants and
they said this is the super mega uh
Ultra you know uh bad variant that's
gonna kill her and and and he stuck to
it then uh the same for Christy gnome
same for some other Republican Governors
now
but for Trump to try to hit him on covet
again it's it's it's politically
suicidal it's insane because Donald
Trump handed the country over to fauci
for a year he just did and and like we
remember that and there's nothing that
you can do to make us not remember it it
happened okay he could have fired fauci
and he didn't and when asked to explain
it after the fact he said the reason he
didn't do is do it do it is because if
he did the media would have attacked him
so he handed the country over to fauci
and the reason he did is because he
didn't want the media to be mad at him
and and that's after three years when
you think what he would learn
immediately mad at him no matter what he
does
um and he put He put fauci on TV every
freaking day we had these we had these
Marathon remember if you recall the
press conferences with fauci Trump could
have put a stop to that and he didn't
and and also when when Ron DeSantis
opened the state back up Trump
criticized him for doing it and said
that it was Reckless and he should do it
he also did the same thing with Kemp in
Georgia Camp opened the state up in
Georgia and Trump criticized it and said
they need to stay locked down
now you can tell you what let's not harp
on that well but he he's bringing it up
he's trying to make them into the into
the uh the advocates for lockdowns
15 days to slow the spread that became
two weeks and a month that was Trump
remember we'll be open by Easter Easter
comes and goes and yeah well never mind
about that you know
uh
and that's why we should be clear about
what the problem is here
it's not that he's criticizing a
potential rival okay that's bound to
happen like that's politics it's gonna
happen it'll get nasty it'll get heated
uh they people try to destroy each other
like that's politics everyone
understands that
but the issue though is number one the
timing
okay
um that it's the timing it's like
it the the GOP underperformed in most
States
but you take the one state where they
did well and you start going after that
guy
and then you go after Junkin which is
another if you look at at the greatest
GOP victories of the last four years
the greatest GOP victory since 2016
happened in Florida and Virginia thanks
to DeSantis and yonkin and those are the
two guys you go after
right now
but beyond that it's also the manner of
the criticism it's not just the CR like
this is not like I said yesterday uh you
will not hear me criticize Trump or
anyone else for being just an a-hole and
being kind of a jerk and being vicious
you know because I'm I am in no spot to
criticize anyone for that and I also
think that there is a time and place to
be that way
and uh especially in politics you need
to be that way that's not the problem
here the problem is it just comes off as
whiny and petulant and pitiful it's just
embarrassing it's not you don't read
that and go well that was mean you read
that and go this is I'm cringing this is
embarrassing you're just complaining
the whole statement is just one long
statement I want credit for this give me
credit that's all it is
and if you're trying to make a political
play to get credit for something then be
smart about it at least again that I
understand is politics
Trump wants to run 2024 he wants to you
know he's getting he's getting
criticized for uh for
what happened in the midterms uh he
wants to change that narrative I get
that that's fair
you got to be smart about the way you do
it you don't do it by putting out these
lengthy rambling statements that go on
for five pages but only have two periods
and where you just repeatedly demand
give me credit for this that's not the
way to do it
you know part of being a fighter is to
be smart and it's it's like I've been
saying for days now it's not running
around and flailing around and just
slapping everything in sight it's it's
being targeted and smart and thinking
about the timing and thinking about the
manner that you go about it that's that
is a smart fight we don't need you don't
need to just be a fighter you have to be
smart and intelligent about the way that
you do it
and then there's also the question of
what are you fighting for exactly
okay what I want what I respect are
fighters who are fighting
to win not just for themselves but for
the country for our civilization like
we're trying to save our civilization
here we're trying to save our culture
that's what you should be fighting for
well this comes off from Trump as
totally ego driven it's all about him
and that has always been his greatest
weakness it has always been his greatest
weakness is that he's driven by ego
and and you know the biggest problem
with that it's not just that it
compels them to do things like this
attacking people who who right now at
least he should be supporting
but also it makes them easily manip you
know he can be easily manipulated
because being ego driven means that okay
if someone criticizes him or or takes uh
you know takes the spotlight away from
him he's going to attack them on the
other side of it if they flatter him and
they compliment him
that he'll love them no matter who they
are
which is why we heard all this stuff
about draining the swamp the Dr the
swamp was never drained from 2016 to
2020 it just wasn't in fact a lot of
these establishment figures ended up in
the White House they got hired to be in
the White House that the the the the the
presidency was handed over essentially
to Jared Kushner John John Bolton you
can't think of a of a of a you know a
more establishment figure than that and
so many other examples and and the
reason that that happens is because
they're able to Cozy up to him and
flatter him and when they do that
um
he'll give them whatever they want
so
what I wish that we could do now
is uh
move
past this
there's going to be a primary and
there's going to be a time for all of
these kinds of conversations and there's
going to be arguments and we're gonna
get mad at each other you know as we get
into the primaries
some of you can be mad at me when we get
into the primaries if you're not already
it's like that's going to happen it's
just that's part of the primary process
um and right now I think we're looking
at a wide open primary and there's it's
going to be like 2016. there's going to
be 90 people in the race
and so it's going to get a little it's
going to get not a little it's going to
get very contentious there's going to be
a lot of fracturing and all that and
that but that's that's that that is part
of the political process you just have
to learn to embrace it and love it and
uh and that's that's because that's what
it's going to be
but we're not even close to there yet
we're two years away I mean we what we
cannot have it's one thing to have a
primary season
where there's a lot of infighting
okay a two-year primary season
two years of this
that is just self-immolation that is
just that is uh that's not gonna help
Trump I don't think it's going to help
the Santos I think right now it's
helping us and as it makes him look
better because he's just ignoring it so
he looks like the bigger man he looks
like the more serious person but I think
eventually he'll end up getting dragged
down into mud too and it just doesn't
it's not gonna help anybody it certainly
will not help conservatives it won't
help the culture it won't help the
country if we have two years of this
so I really hope it doesn't
come to that but a lot of this uh it's
it's up to Trump you know if he
continues to do this for two years then
it's going to continue to be in the
headlines continue to be in the
spotlight the media is gonna the media
loves it they love this
they could not be happier about it
and and anything Trump says attacking
DeSantis or any other Republican the
media will take that and they will
amplify that they'll put it on
billboards they want everyone to see it
because they love this
so it's not entirely up to Trump but
it's largely up to him whether or not
this is going to continue for four years
and or two years and everyone hurts
everyone is you know everyone is is goes
down in flames because of it
or
can he move past his wounded ego at the
moment
yeah he's getting blamed he thinks
unfairly for some of this stuff
okay just like that's that happens when
you're a position of leadership you get
blamed okay if you want credit you're
gonna get the blame too it's how it goes
but let's focus on the country right now
all right
um
this is from daily wire Chloe Cole is a
d transitioned 18 year old woman who was
of course at our rally a few few weeks
ago our end child mutilation rally
um a detransition 18 year old woman
announced turn 10 on Thursday to sue the
hospital and affiliate a medical group
that facilitated her medical transition
as a minor according to the press
release coal represented by the Dylan
Law Group and lamandre and John LLP in
conjunction with the center for American
Liberty sent a letter of intent to sue
the Permanente Medical Group Kaiser
Foundation Health Plan and Kaiser
Foundation hospitals who have performed
supervised and or advised transgender
hormone therapy and surgical
interventions for Chloe Cole when she
was between 13 and 17 years old
they'll also be seeking punitive damages
based on the evidence of malice
oppression and fraud Cole said My
Teenage life has been the culmination of
excruciating pain regret and most
importantly Injustice I have been
emotionally and physically damaged and
stunted by so-called medical
professionals in my most important
developmental period I was butchered by
an institution that we trust more than
anything else in our lives the letter of
intent to sue outlines the experimental
nature and off-label use of the puberty
blockers crosses sex hormones and double
mastectomy surgery offered to Coal which
lack long-term studies to support their
use in gender medicine and alleges that
the treatments amount to Medical
experimentation and she's obviously
exactly correct about this
uh you know I told you this when we had
her when we had clinical speak at her
rally she's an extremely impressive
young woman uh to to be just at that
environment in the rally
she's getting up there and sharing her
story which is a
an unbelievably traumatic and horrific
story
and while she's sharing it you know on
stage in front of thousands of people
she's got these uh you know these
left-wing vultures in the crowd
screaming at her and cussing at her and
she was able to to and that is that is
not an easy environment even for a
trained public speaker which she isn't
you know because she just
became sort of a public figure only
recently
um
but she was able to
persevere through that and I found that
very impressive and this even more so um
and it takes a lot of Courage I mean I
know
the kind of blowback that I get from the
trans activists
and it for me it is constant and it is
intense and it is it involves
everything you could possibly imagine
including things that I can't I still
can't even talk about for security
reasons uh but it's just they throw
everything they can at you they are
utterly soulless demons who uh if you
oppose them they want to destroy you
they want to kill you they want you dead
uh and I give that
how much worse must it be for her
because on top of
opposing them
they also there's also the element in
their Twisted minds of betrayal
like she's betrayed them you know
um she's a uh you know an apostate
basically in their minds
and on top of that she has first-hand
experience she is revealing secrets
that they don't want out
a lot of stuff that she talks about
about what happened with her and and the
the the the effects of these drugs and
these procedures they all know that they
know it from experience
you know that they they know how how how
Graham and grotesque and horrible a lot
of this stuff is they they they
themselves are also living through it
but they don't want us to know
and she's revealing the secrets and now
she's going after you know now she's
going after the the top dogs here I mean
Kaiser Permanente she's going after you
know the the The Butchers themselves the
pharmaceutical industry and this is
exactly what needs to happen
right speaking of The Butchers Libs of
tick tock has this video of the director
of the gender health program at the
Children's Hospital of Minnesota
um let's watch a little bit of this
so let's start with how kids understand
gender identity well from the age of
about two kids can understand gender
differences now this is mostly based on
physical characteristics and Anatomy is
they sort and put people into categories
boys and girls mommies and daddies
kids at two are actually very good at
putting things into categories and
they're very concrete and binary
thinkers so this is a fun and easy task
for them
as they move into age three and four
they then begin to figure out where they
fit they've seen the categories and
they're turning the lens inward to
discover where they fit in the
categories that have been explained to
them most of which are boy and girl
now they often develop more
sophisticated understanding of physical
characteristics and Anatomy around this
time and they're often not shy about
sharing their discoveries with us they
may exclaim I'm a girl and I have a
vagina
and that may happen in the
pediatrician's office or in the checkout
line at the grocery store
they have figured out their place in the
world and they are claiming it
it shouldn't surprise you then that some
transgender kids are also claiming their
identities as young as three and four
years old they know the categories they
know how they should feel inside based
on their anatomy And they also know that
the way that they see themselves doesn't
line up with other people's expectations
from as young as some kids can talk
they're explaining to their parents the
truth about their identities and I have
three boys or rather I have three kids
six six and four who were assigned male
at Birth and continue to identify as
boys and when our kids were growing up
we tried to expand their gender
categories just a little bit so instead
of saying to them these are boy parts
and these are not that God help those
boys we taught them that um this this
person has three sons
God help them I mean really God God help
them because she's not going to
you know uh my daughter my now
three-year-old daughter
had her birthday a month ago and on
her birthday uh I did what all adults do
and little kids have birthdays you know
you quiz them on their own age how old
are you turn in today
and I asked her to this a couple of
times and variously throughout the day
she was turning uh 20
she was turning a hundred she was
turning one
she was turning seven every time you ask
her you get a different answer you know
um
and so when she declares
they ask her how are you turning
20.
is that her figuring out her place in
the world
that's that's that statement she's
making about herself that's her that's I
asked her about herself
uh her own identity she said she was 20
years old I guess she's 20 years old
trying to move out of the house get a
job
right
no when kids make declarations about
themselves
at this age at this young age whether
it's they're talking about their age
talking about their sex uh talking about
really anything about themselves
when they make declarations there there
are a couple of things happening here
one of them is that they're very often
just repeating what they've already what
they've been told
okay and then I repeat it perfectly
because we did tell my daughter that
she's turning three and she it's just
couldn't quite grasp it
but um very often if you if you tell
your kids something about themselves if
you if you affirm a certain idea then
they'll just like go around repeating it
so there's there's repetition
you know there's the regurgitation of
what they've been told
there's also just Mindless kid Babel
anyone who's been around young kids
knows this or should know it that little
kids they simply Babble they walk around
saying words and the words don't they
don't even don't make any sense
um
the making declarations that have no
reflection don't reflect reality
whatsoever they're just saying things
yeah think about a kid is that the child
has no has no capacity for an internal
monologue
and uh there are some people who grow up
and they still never develop and these
people are the bane of my existence they
have no capacity to think inside their
own heads so everything that pops in the
head they just say and for an adult you
know I could say well I would expect you
to develop some capacity to keep your
mouth shut at this point but for a kid
that's just how it goes
so there's a lot of babbling going on
but then you know what else they're
doing
there's the Babbling there's the
regurgitation of of information they've
been told and there's also oftentimes
they can they can say something about
themselves
and it's really a question
it's like they don't know if this is
true they're just sort of saying it and
they're and they're looking to get the
reaction from the adult to tell them yes
that's true or no it isn't
that's why going back to my daughter and
her age
when I asked her how old she's turning
she didn't really say it like it was
more like a question 20
it's like sure exactly so she's just
throwing something out she's throwing a
word out there and a number and she's
looking for the reaction for me so I can
tell her whether that's true or not
because I know more about who my
three-year-old daughter is than she does
I know a lot more about who she is than
she does
I understand a lot more about the world
and I understand a lot more about her
and so she is coming to me and to my
wife
to figure out not just what's going on
in the world but also what's going on
with her who she is
and so that explains
a young boy who says I'm a girl
either he's babbling incoherently or
he's repeating what he's been told by
his abusive parent
or he's asking a question he's not sure
it's a question
you know you could put an MI in front of
it am I not I'm a girl am I
and it's up to us as adults with our
what it's supposed to be superior grasp
on reality
to guide them in the right direction to
answer the question
based on what we understand about
reality
but most children are not or many
children these days don't don't get that
all right this is from wpde.com a
teenager in New Hampshire has become the
first transgender contestant to win a
local Miss America organization beauty
pageant
Brian Gwynn
didn't even change his name he's still
Brian 19 won Sunday night's pageant to
become Miss greater Dairy 2023 which
Awards a uh where's the winner a crown a
title and a scholarship
I think we have the footage of this uh
of this young man winning the beauty
pageant yeah we do uh let's let's watch
that
can we skip to the good part
[Music]
so
as you can see that's uh
you know that's the offensive lineman
with the Detroit Lions that just won the
uh the Miss America Pageant there it's
like there's a an obese man
was awarded the beauty pageant winner
um
Gwen announced on Instagram in the 100
Year history of Miss America I have
officially become the first transgender
title holder within the Miss America
organization
no words can describe the feeling of
having the opportunity to serve my
community and represent my community for
the very first time at Miss New
Hampshire I am so honored to be crowned
your new Miss greater Dairy 2023 and I
am thrilled to show you all what I have
up my sleeves
really don't want to see
this will be an amazing year
there's a few things going on here one
of them it goes back to something I
talked about with Joe Rogan uh on Monday
and he brought up
that you know this this gender ideology
stuff it it affords people there's of
course a lot of narcissism involved in
it and that's that's certainly the case
here but also force people the
opportunity to to like uh
earn something or have an achievement
despite having achieved nothing like you
don't have to work for you don't have to
do anything you don't have to accomplish
anything
and suddenly you you have achieved
something
that's a lot of this so this guy has uh
the first in a hundred years I'm a
Trailblazer he didn't do anything he put
on a dress he just showed up at this uh
at this beauty pageant
and he won as soon as he walked in the
door because for the people deciding who
the winner is he was he presented to
them an opportunity to Virtue signal and
they took it you know this is the
Northeast this is New Hampshire they're
gonna they're gonna take that
opportunity as soon as he presents it to
them so he did nothing
and yet he gets to claim this title for
himself I'm the first in 100 years to
what an achievement
so there's a lot of that but also also
consider that
you know I know what the body positivity
stuff that uh you know we're we're
entering a world where very often
you know you know an obese woman maybe
could win a title like that but I think
what's what's more likely I mean look at
all the other you see him and then
compare him to all of the actual women
on stage
and you notice a difference
well there are there's a number of
differences
but one of them is that all the other he
is morbidly obese and none of the other
women are none of the actual women are I
should say
the point is that
if he looked exactly like that
but was actually a woman
Not only would he not have one Miss
America he would not have been allowed
on the stage
and that's it's kind of interesting too
because I've I've pointed out before
that when it comes to this body
positivity stuff
the one thing missing are men usually
because usually when you see you know
when some uh brand puts out an
advertisement celebrating body
positivity with a with an obese model
you know it's it's almost always women
you very rarely see a guy with a big fat
beer gut you know appearing in a in a
dove ad or something like that
um as a champion of body positivity the
plus size models very rarely men
so body positivity celebrating obesity
almost always applies to women not men
except in this case
if the man is pretending to be a woman
that's how twisted Things Are okay I
also want to mention one other thing
let's put this up so Eric swalwell
yesterday tweeted this
um
Eric fart smell as I call him because
you know what I
I can come up with some some mature and
clever nicknames like fart smell maybe
Donald Trump should take some
hints for me uh so he's so Eric swalwell
is responding to a quote from Senator
Tim Scott and Senator Tim Scott says
we're putting parents back in charge of
their kids education
swallow responds please tell me what I'm
missing here what are we doing what are
we going to do next putting patience in
charge of their own surgeries clients in
charge of their own trials when did we
stop trusting experts this is so stupid
you're right fart smell that is it is
that is in fact so stupid in fact I
don't even know where to begin
uh we'll start with this first of all
public school teachers are not subject
matter experts okay
like almost certainly the person you're
the the this your child's seventh grade
math teacher is not an expert
mathematician they're not bringing
actual scientists in to teach science so
they in fact are not experts in the
subject
that they're teaching
now you could say that well but they're
experts in teaching are they though
yeah I mean generally speaking and there
are there are some very good Public
School teachers out there certainly
but generally speaking is there a lot of
evidence
that all or even most public school
teachers are experts in teaching
do we see the evidence where's the the
proofs in the pudding so let's look at
the pudding here and what we find are
test scores declining literacy declining
everything's declining I mean a bunch of
kids graduating who uh end up in these
dumb guy on the street interviews being
asked about you know what what century
was the Civil War fought in and like you
know they say the 12th century or
something like that
so that's what the public school is
producing there's there's not a lot of
evidence that the people in charge of
the public schools people doing the
teaching are generally speaking experts
but then also
um
he says oh we're going to put clients in
charge of the in charge of Defending
themselves at trial
well yeah in fact you you have the
constitutional right to defend yourself
at trial
you don't have to we have the right to
do it
our patients going to be in charge of
their surgeries
in a sense yes
you have to decide that you want the
surgery and consent to it
they can't force you to get it
you you have rights as a patient don't
you
so as a defendant of trial you have
basic rights as a patient you have basic
rights
so this to me this this these are
analogies that I would use if I wanted
to defend the rights of parents to have
a say over their child's education
so he's making exactly the opposite
point
and uh also keep in mind what he's what
he's what he's responding to
like the claim from Tim Scott is not
that uh Tim Scott is not saying let's
abolish the public school system I'm
saying that but that's not what Tim
Scott Tim Scott's not the kind of
Republicans going to say that I don't
think there's any Republican right now
who will unfortunately
somebody's actually responding to is not
let's tear down the public school system
and get rid of it as great as that would
be in my opinion it's rather just
parents should have a say
like your kids are are going into this
building for six hours a day five days a
week nine months a year for 12 13 years
you should have a say over what happens
there you should have a role in that
Ben swalwell saying no you should have
no role at all
no role no rights
and to make his point
he cites examples
where people do have a a crucial role
and they do have rights in those
examples
more Brilliance from Eric's well let's
get to the comment section
s
[Music]
Phantom 04 says I cannot express how
infuriated I am by this whole student
loan thing I didn't go to college I
worked my tail off to support my
four-year-old son and I couldn't even
take him to an aquarium on vacation for
a day because I couldn't afford it
thanks to the inflation of Brandon and
the Democrats yet these spoiled brats
who waste more on soy lattes in a month
and people like me spend on anything
frivolous in a year feel entitled to
reach into my pocket to help pay for
their vacations or dining out screw them
and fjb and his corrupt party that
spends our tax dollars with complete and
total disregard and gets rich off of
their positions and their corruption
amen could not agree more and this is
the kind of righteous indignation this
is the kind of moral outrage that we
should have
about these issues
and honestly I don't see enough of it
and what we hear from
you know the media and uh what we hear
from the the the milk toast squishes is
too much outrage people are too angry
let's let's turn down the uh the dial a
little bit let's turn down the volume
I could not disagree more I think the
exact opposite is the case there's not
nearly enough outrage
just about the student loan thing in
that on its own
you know there should be an eruption of
moral outrage over this because what
they're what it happened here is morally
outrageous
stealing money from hard-working people
not just to pay off someone else's
Financial Obligations but as we found
out and as as surprises nobody with with
two brain cells in their head uh that
money isn't even being used for that
purpose but it's being used so that
these people can go out to eat and have
vacations and and the rest of it
um Sean says I think that blind man
video or possibly a similar situation
was discussed by Anthony Anthony cumia
and uh and Gavin McGinnis a while back
they made an accurate observation that
many not all certainly but many female
officers are overly aggressive and
combative in these situations because
they feel the need to overcompensate for
perceived power imbalance many feel they
have to constantly prove their worth by
being more aggressive than need be but
that only ends up escalating situations
that didn't require overall female
officers tend to be a liability to the
force uh well they must not have been
talking about this exact video if it was
a while back because this you know the
thing we talked about daily cancellation
yesterday
just happened a few days ago
but I do think that uh it's not popular
to say of course no true thing is
I I do think there's a lot to be said
for that point of view you know
um and it's it's the problem that you
run to if you're a female police officer
and you're out on the job like you're
dealing with a lot of people who you
have no physical control over it if they
decide that they want to resist you or
they want to attack you
um you're not going to have any way to
do that aside from like you know
resorting to
no deadly force basically
um
but there is there is a physical power
imbalance and that's the situation when
you have a female police officer
almost every suspect they deal with
will be able to easily overpower them
and you know that going in
and then you might have a problem of
overcompensation which yeah I do think
it seems like that's what happened here
and then there are other cases there was
a case and I was looking for it uh
there's a video that I was looking for I
couldn't find it but there was a case
recently of an officer's female officer
got in trouble because she was on the
scene when there was a fight there was a
guy getting assaulted and she just was
kind of like standing there didn't do
anything about it so it's the opposite
of over compensating that case you
didn't do anything
but also like
first of all what can she do aside from
using deadly force and but if she did
that then everybody would complain that
this was police brutality so it's like a
being thrust into these
no-win situations
and police officers are very often in
known situations but I think if you're a
female police officer uh there are many
more no-win situations I mean almost
every situation is known situation
um
all right
let's see this guy is the limit says to
put it simply when deciding which of
your personal choices and freedoms are
correct a help for helpful a helpful
metric to use is if everybody made this
choice would civilization flourish or
would it decay it's a decent response to
Rogan's libertarian position on marriage
yes people have the choice to not have
children and to travel and read books as
he put it but what if everybody did that
goodbye future Generations yeah I think
that's a good way to put it's a good
argument of course there's there are
always the the responses cheap responses
like well uh if everybody was an
engineer you know then then society
would collapse uh if everybody was a
firefighters Society of the collapse
because we need people to do other
things aside from those jobs
um but you mean it on a more fundamental
level like that you're talking about
like not like a job but just how a
lifestyle how you're living your life
and um
and look if
and so there's one thing I tried to
communicate to
Joe Rogan but if you if we decide as
society that marriage is meaningless and
if everybody adopts that Viewpoint as
increasingly that's the direction we're
heading in then you have you're correct
the collapse of civilization
which I would consider a negative
personally
recessions aren't recessions inflation
is good men or women if you're more
confused than usual lately it's by
Design the left thinks they have a
monopoly on the definition of words and
they can silence you but they can't and
if you simply push back the House of
Cards collapses just look at what is a
woman my film which caused a rift in the
space-time Continuum just because I
asked a question the month that came out
the daily wire had more members sign up
than at any other time in its history
more than 5 000 audio audience ratings
The Rotten Tomatoes later and the film
still has people talking which is great
because the more we bring these
conversations out into the open and the
more we confront the madness the sooner
it will hopefully end if you haven't
seen it yet go to dailywire.com Walsh to
become a member and watch the film today
now let's get to our daily cancellation
foreign
daily cancellation we head to the Future
site of the Obama Presidential Center in
Chicago the center began Construction in
2021 it's supposed to open in 2026 in
fact
um it was supposed to begin construction
years before 2021 but various delays got
in the way uh now that it's finally
started it will take half a decade to
complete now keep in mind the Empire
State Building was constructed in one
year nearly a century ago but these days
things that we should be able to do in
half the time
um that it you know that it would have
taken 100 years ago instead take us five
or ten times as long
for another example of this phenomenon
of course we could just see vote
counting procedures is another example
as for construction we should note that
not only does it take longer to build
stuff but that the stuff we're building
is of a much lower quality compared to
what we built 100 years ago
so 100 years ago they would build it
faster and better than we do now
um the bad news then is that it takes us
forever to build
but the good news is that once it's
built it will be cheap and flimsy and
may not even last as long as it took to
get the permits to construct it and it
will also be ugly
almost everything we build is hideously
ugly the ugly the Obama Presidential
Center will certainly be no exception as
you can see here we put the the picture
up on the screen it is a it's a
monstrosity it is a pockmarked misshapen
asymmetrical hunk of building material
plopped right into the middle of the
city looks like something that a group
of third graders could build in an
afternoon
only it will take them five years to
create this gargantuan eyesore
it's no surprise that Obama's Center
would be uh so horrifically ugly and
ridiculous he is a leftist after all and
leftism celebrates ugliness it chooses
ugly over beautiful intentionally on
principle
in this case Obama has chosen a design
that looks something like a colossal
Wi-Fi modem after it's been kicked on a
flight of stairs or something
and why will this Abomination take so
long to construct why does everything
take so long to construct well for the
same reason that everything is
everything else is inefficient these
days bureaucracy lawsuits incompetence
red tape Etc
almost anything uh can slow the work
down or bring it to a grinding halt
anything including a rope this is from
the New York Post here's the latest
construction at the Obama Presidential
Center in Chicago has been temporarily
halted after a noose was discovered at
the work site Thursday morning Lakeside
Alliance the construction company
building the 830 million dollar Center
said it immediately notified of police
after the news was reported on the
premises according located in Jackson
Park the company told the post in a
statement that it suspended all
operations on site in order to provide
its employees with an additional series
of anti-bias training citing a zero
tolerance policy for any form of bias or
hate on a work site the company
additionally said it was offering a one
hundred thousand dollar reward to find
the culprit quote we are horrified that
this would occur on our site and we are
offering a 100 000 reward to help find
the individual or individuals
responsible for this shameful act
Lakeside Alliance remains committed to
providing a work environment where
everyone can feel safe be their best
self and is treated with dignity and
respect according to the statement it
will not surprise you to learn that um
there is no picture of the Noose
we haven't seen a picture of it hate
crime nooses are a bit like Bigfoot lots
of people see them but we never seem to
get a good picture of one which makes
sense of course it's not like everyone
carries a camera around in their pockets
these days
be that as it may uh there were many
denunciations of the Unseen news the
post continues quote the Obama the Obama
Foundation denounced the incident as a
Shameless Act of cowardice and hate
designed to get attention and divide us
our priority is protecting the health
and safety of our Workforce the
foundation said in a statement to the
post we have notified authorities who
are investigating the incident Illinois
governor JB pritzker also condemned the
ACT hate has no place in Illinois he
said the news is more than a symbol of
racism it is a heart-stopping reminder
of the violence and Terror inflicted on
black Americans for centuries
now we should note that nooses are an
epidemic on construction sites I don't
know if you knew this recently eight
nooses were found on an Amazon
construction site they kept shutting
down the the building on the site
because they kept finding all these
nuises a noose was also found at the
site of a new Facebook building
in fact as the Washington Post reported
last year dozens of nooses have shown up
on construction sites all over the
country
they reported at the time quote
black workers who make up only six
percent of the sector have found many of
the 55 nooses reported at 40 work sites
since 2015.
indeed the news problem is so pervasive
that as the Washington Post reports some
of the nooses are invisible
quote the Reverend Larry Bullock
president and chief executive of the U.S
minority contractors Association said he
spends his days worrying about invisible
nooses in the construction industry
Bullock who was black says too many
companies circumvent diversity and
inclusion requirements by by either
skirting statutes or budgeting for fines
for failing to meet them he also lists
the lack of expertise lack of capital
and struggles with Labor Management
relations as some of the greatest
obstacles for minority-owned firms in
construction the migration of apprentice
programs outside of urban areas has
dampened diversity efforts he said as
has the elimination of school
curriculums that gave black use an
earlier introduction into the trades all
this makes it difficult to hire youth
that look like us he said it's a vicious
vicious cycle of trying to address the
systemic racism in construction
this man is seeing invisible nooses
everywhere it is surely a sign of
systemic racism where else is a symptom
of his own mental illness I don't know
now let me um
make a few points here and and state the
obvious
first of all
there are two possible explanations for
why people keep finding ropes on
construction sites one is that the
construction industry one of the most
racially diverse Industries in the
country with at least a third of all
workers being Hispanic is also infested
somehow with white supremacists white
supremacists who sign up to work with
racial minorities all day that's one
possible reason why there are ropes on
construction sites the other possible
reason why there are ropes on
construction sites is that a
construction site
is a construction site
perhaps you find ropes there for the
same reason you find Hammers and nails
and lumber a rope is a tool used in
construction
often these ropes are tied into knots
that might look something like a noose
it's very common you take ropes and you
tie them into knots so you can do things
with them you can make pulleys and you
can you know carry things you can do
things with them
it's very common indeed walk through any
construction site and you are guaranteed
to stumble across all manner of ropes
cords cables
which will be tied into various sorts of
knots and configurations
if you're going to immediately assume
that a rope on a construction site is
meant to send a racist message you may
as well immediately assume that a bucket
of black paint is intended to be to be
used for blackface or something
you have jumped to the most extreme and
bizarre conclusion
and in the process you have leapt right
over simpler and more banal and more
obvious and more innocent ones
second point it's true that not every
alleged news necessarily has an innocent
explanation
some of them indeed could be put there
intentionally and for nefarious purposes
that's possible
but if they were
the most logical assumption based on
recent historical precedent is that they
are put there as a hoax
like if they're put there intentionally
for nefarious purposes it's almost
certainly a hoax
because it always is
far be it for me to suggest a race hoax
in Chicago certainly not a place known
for such things but given that nearly
every new story I mean nearly every
single one either turns out to be an
innocuous rope misinterpreted or an
intentional hoax what else are we
supposed to think
of course the left exists in an
alternate reality which is why neither
the media nor the Obama Foundation nor
the governor's office are even taking
into consideration the possibility that
the Noose is innocuous or a hoax
never mind how these stories play out
nearly 100 of the time
the boy cried wolf a thousand times and
was lying a thousand times
but each time with each new cry they
assume that it must be real
and don't even take into consideration
the possibility that it isn't
I would call it Insanity except that
it's all intentional
they are not being deceived
they are rather of course a part of the
deception
and that's why everyone involved in this
story
including the Obama Center itself
actually for being so ugly
everyone and everything is canceled
and that'll do it for this portion of
the show is move over to the members
block hope to see you there if not talk
to you on Monday Godspeed
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]